und nun ist es an der zeit einen ganz
besonderen mann zu feiern
verkehrsminister an die steuer oder wie
enge freunde ihn nennen das
missverständnis des jahres ist neue
geflügel und geworden berliner egal ob
bahn mobilfunk oder maut der an dem
steuerkreuz versaut geben ich selber
geiger ist egal
wegen der pkw-maut wirft ihnen der
bundesrechnungshof sogar offenen
rechtsbruch vor
und trotzdem sitzt der mann weiter fest
am kabinettstisch was muss man
eigentlich heutzutage machen und bei
merkels trümmer trug vor auszufliegen
da könnten sogar fotos auftauchen von
der minister im hof der mit einem
rasierten ponys und prinz andrew ein
kleiner müsste zurücktreten nicht mal
das pony
obwohl ich höre gerade bei der bahn gibt
es ihre fortschritte denn ich habe
gestern auf meinen beiden zugfahrten
pünktlich von berlin nach bamberg und
wieder zurück hoch motivierte
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter kennen
gelernt die teilweise sehr lange bei der
bahn sind wie angehen und giuseppe oder
quereinsteiger sind ein jahr bei der
bahn sind wie ramona und frank erwische
für ramona und frank jetzt war pünktlich
ja aber noch nicht weil der
verkehrsminister damit gefahren ist oder
und übrigens am nachbargleis dann ganz
viele andere fahrgäste die waren
irgendwie sauer weil der zug nach
braunschweig schon wieder 90 minuten
verspätung hatte
das waren der peter die nadine der york
holen der jamal die gisela
[Applaus]
aber viel besser damit der bahn können
die ja in zukunft alle beim scooter zur
arbeit fahren dem lieblingsgefährt vom
anti wo ich ja eigentlich sehen sie mich
geht nicht ich bin im toten winkel hier
aber dann bleib doch da du vollpfosten
heute-show verleiht andreas scheuer im
grunde ja für sein lebenswerk den
goldenen verbrennungs vollpfosten nach
neuesten meldungen kostet uns der maut
vertrag den er unbedingt vor dem urteil
unterschreiben musste mindestens 700
millionen euro
guck mal hier unten das schreckt man die
kohle rein und dann ist glaube ich
selbst erklärend oder lieber an die du
bist gar nicht liebt und dass hier bis
dein lied performt von max mutzke
[Applaus]
kennst du das auch
wenn du alles noch warm um's keine angst
in ein
von bob so viel mehr
motto diesen krise
breitbandausbau auf dem
er will das ist alles
an die wand
er lenkt die bahn
in den abgrund stück für stück und man
wünscht sich selbst den alex dobrindt
zurück
und dann an die fluten
ist guter jedem ort um das zu verhindern
vor
einen neuen job
wie schon
[Musik]
halt
so schädlich und halb so teuer denn als
glückskeks
[Musik]
der
hier
[Musik]
kosten
kannst sowieso nicht
es gibt so viele
so viel will sind die wehr
[Musik]
mit schmuck
[Applaus]
die holtzbrinck hat
ja
wer häufig faszinierend so aus ich muss
bekloppt sein meine damen und herren und
es gibt direkt den nächsten für alle
deutschen gibt es jetzt den rettet unser
auto vollpfosten schauen sie mal in der
tiefergelegten tuning variante geil oder
denn das automobil das wissen sie das
automobil an sich steht 2009 10 unter
dauerbeschuss
manche sagen ihm droht langfristig
vielleicht sogar der märtyrertod wenn
auch in teilen selbst verschuldet weil
die branche so lange weltweite trends
verpennt hat hier die umwelthilfe hat
mal den realen co2 ausstoß von politiker
dienstwagen überprüft also den realen
ausstoß und sie ahnen nicht wer da den
vogel abschießt demnach hält keiner von
237 untersuchten dienstwagen den derzeit
geltenden eu co2 flotten grenzwert
negativ spitzenreiter unter den
bundesministern als verkehrsminister
andreas scheuer
[Applaus]
und alle irgendwie schon es gibt nur ein
neuer gott sei dank gibt es noch ein
jahr
das umweltbundesamt hat jetzt unter
anderem vorgeschlagen die
pendlerpauschale zu streichen die ja
bald erhöht wird wissen sie damit
weniger leute auto fahren ja man kann in
deutschland nicht sachlich über das auto
diskutiert es geht nicht wir hatten
allein 2009 10 mindestens drei hyper
aufgeregte tempolimit debatten damaligen
doch alle argumente zum tempolimit auf
dem tisch wir sind eines der letzten
länder dass kein tempolimit auf
autobahnen hat
ich glaube nepal und noch ein paar
andere ungewöhnliche länder wie
afghanistan haben das ganze nicht weil
wir haben de facto auch keine autobahnen
ja gut dafür kann ich in nepal auf dem
esel mit 300 sachen in die malaria hoch
kacheln auf autobahnstrecken mit
tempolimit sterben deutlich weniger
menschen als auf strecken ohne ende
trotzdem sage ich voraus wird es ein
generelles tempolimit hier niemals geben
weil wir dafür schlicht genetisch nicht
gemacht sind
[Musik]
der deutsche autofahrer der beste
autofahrer der welt
neueste forschungen belegen dass
deutsche gehirn ist eher niedrige
geschwindigkeiten leider gar nicht
ausgelegt unter 50 km h gerät der fahrer
schlagartig in einer tiefschlafphase
zwischen 50 und 80 kocht er sich kaffee
und telefoniert ab tempo 120 er reinigt
der deutsche gern den innenraum des
fahrzeugs erst oberhalb von 130 schaut
er auch mal auf die straße sein gehirn
wird aktiv augen und ohren arbeiten
normal und jenseits von 200 sachen
werden endlich auch seine
geschlechtsorgane voll durchblutet und
der autofahrer kann sich fortpflanzen
also könnte er wenn er seine frau nicht
neulich überfahren hätte
[Musik]
ja so aber immerhin kommt ja jetzt die
große wende zum e-auto freunde unsere
deutsche industrie setzt alles nur noch
auf e
ja warum falls nicht mehr anders geht
weil vor allem die elektroauto quoten in
china sieht zwingen
im moment sind e-autos auf zweitwagen
von gutverdienenden städtern und unser
strommix enthält leider auch noch jede
menge kohle ist nicht gut aber egal
die zeit drängt und hier kommt ein
leicht abgewandeltes altes sprichwort
gerade in den städten gibt es riesige
einsatz märkte für elektrofahrzeuge und
ja und wenn die großen
automobilhersteller sich nicht beeilen
und werden kleinere ihnen ganze stücke
kuchen vom brot nehmen
ja klar natürlich
der täter hat ja völlig recht ohne
kuchen kriegst du brauchst gar nicht
runter so es gibt aber auch gute
nachrichten für die autoindustrie also
jetzt nicht für die deutsche aber
immerhin tesla chef elon musk will in
brandenburg
sie haben richtig gehört in brandenburg
seine erste europäische liga fabrik
bauen
angepeilter produktionsbeginn 2021 ich
glaube der faktor in elon musk da nicht
einkalkuliert sind brandenburgische
handwerker
wir schalten wir live nach grünheide zur
ico clubbosse von hoch- und tiefbau
clubbosse aus neuruppin der klamotte
seid ihr denn noch im zeitplan
also erwäge ich will nicht so viel
versprechen aber wenn wir alles wie am
schnürchen läuft könnte es sein also im
absoluten optimalfall dass wir noch im
januar den grundstein fürs zweite
dixi-klo legen
aber da müssen dann wirklich schon alle
ihre werke von 10 mio seo mystic
anständig alter handwerker wird sehr
viel mist mist mist also elon musk ich
weiß nicht ob ihnen das gleis elon musk
geht tatsächlich aus von baubeginn im
ersten quartal 2020 also mal punkt 1 was
ist überhaupt für name elon mein name
ist evonik kaufen
im übrigen habe ich für unsere neuen
herrn mas genau zwei worte
brandenburgische bauvorlagen verordnung
wie gesagt so e mail an alte muskete wo
ist denn dein grundstücks
entwässerungsplan gemäß § 7 absatz 3 wo
es sie nicht grundstücks
entwässerungsplan antwort gibt's nur im
deutschen die kappe aus spaß mal eine
bei google übersetzer da ist in der
server explodiert also wenn da bis zu
10.000 arbeitsplätze geschaffen werden
könnte man aber auch mal ein auge
zudrücken
entschuldigung ich gebe ja wirklich alle
ja ich habe mir sogar extra ded lexikon
handwerker deutsch englisch geholt da
kann ich dem herrn mas die wichtigsten
deutschen handwerker setzte beibringen
klassiker wie normalerweise müsste die
teilten usually sich holt oder nach fest
kommt lose after tight kampflos und und
natürlich brauchen sie dafür unbedingt
eine rechnung kennen wie die black
please und und jetzt liefern sie sich
also eine art rennen mit der
benachbarten br baustelle ja genau
schneckenrennen brandenburg hat ja einen
hang zu verhängten großprojekten
lausitzring oder dieses zeppelinhalle in
der letzten spaßbad ist umso lustiger
die offizielle homepage des landes
brandenburg es kann so einfach sein
in klammern wenn man es woanders macht
probieren wir einmal eine giga fabrik
warum nicht offen für neue zeit immer da
kommt ja der kollege der die
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung macht
wegen der 70 hektar kiefernwald die wir
hier weggehen und eins hast du eine
bedrohte art ja von fledermäusen
alles klar ist etwa aus giga fabrik am
aus wir packen ein feierabend licht aus
rohr weihnachten schittkowski mein arzt
hat mir verboten mich weiterhin so
aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünscht überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt das xenix ein beschissenes
ab
[Musik]